good morning Millennials I have a
personal announcement I feel as if since
I brought the toasters on the beginning
of this journey it's only right that I
end it full circle with thudding
everyone now that I got my period
yesterday I want a clap that I'm at the
end to me is sad and you know what it's
like I don't know why I thought I was
pregnant like I was very much on
schedule like nothing was so crazy but I
just like I mean people say like when
you knew intuition and then people
always say like I just knew I was
pregnant so I was like thought I was
having one of those moments but I wasn't
know and I was just gonna like say
something I was gonna say five minute so
anyways to show after Peter Herman is a
moot point no I know it's just like what
I was like living yesterday like
breathing and I was like why am I even
alive like no my life can end because
Peter Herman like loved us my life's
work is done Peter loved the show the
toasters loved the show we love the show
like we're all on this Peter Herman hi
yeah and I guess the only thing that
couldn't you know suffice today would be
a real-life vampire yeah um and Theodore
for tréminis here because we just needed
some sunlight
Theodore for chairman is here
strategically because Jason and Caitlin
just got a dog and the dog Larry arrived
like four hours after Jason had to leave
for this trip so in exchange for Jason
respecting the hell out of the choice
and missing you know meeting his dog I
brought him a dog yeah just to tide him
over and then we can like find out more
about their dog and you know get all the
team you know because you know I didn't
realize I was reading some of the
comments for the questions on Jason
their innate their dog's name is ramen
noodle and they're calling him noodle
and then the old golden retriever that
she had with Sean was doodle so he
that's intentional no Tucker was Tucker
doodle right the job already had the
name ramen noodle no yeah are you sure
yes the dog has been alive for a year
was a rescue and the dog was previously
named ramen noodle I think that's the
sort of thing where that when they met
the dog and they found it that was his
name it was like meant to be yeah
because I think you know I don't know
everything but it was really sad when
she lost yeah of course it was creepy
writing yeah it was very much like she
was always with that dog and definitely
has a hole in her heart that this dog is
gonna replace and finding out that that
was the name was definitely made it like
kismet yeah no I agree I love that I
didn't really I thought they were naming
at that like you know when you guys do
we're always trying to like replace our
childhood dog right and I thought that's
which wish I didn't even like not even
in a like a you don't have to hide that
sort of way like it was a big loss you
know
the dogs look exactly the same and I've
been watching all of her stories and it
is mad [ __ ] cute like I it's making
me want to now like get a new dog so I
can like have those first few moments
with him I know I feel her I know I say
this like every few months but like I
feel as though I'm ready for a dog I
don't I won't get excited anyway no
there was a time when I was literally on
my way to Texas I was gonna I had plans
to go to Dallas in May and I was gonna
pick up for tremens cousin yeah but then
I kept him for the weekend and what I
still need to figure out is the paws the
paws of it all you have to let go and
let God like there's no way to literally
properly clean the dog's paws they have
to go out four times today at least so
like you're gonna clean the paws four
times a day like you a part of you just
has to let it go unless I was able to
find the shoes for the dogs I mean I get
what you mean like the city is so
disgusting and it should you definitely
took a blacklight to my sheets like
they're gross but I just don't here
because I have such a love in my know
like I'm and you don't care that's the
thing I don't know that I could ever get
to a place of not caring even if I could
this half would never so it's just
logistically it's tough for us but
shorty needs to come out with some sort
of product about like dogs paws because
it's so unsanitary like even people live
in the suburbs like they get mud and
grass like there needs to be something
and I'm calling on shark tank
to fix this problem I agree I
wholeheartedly agree in the words of
Mark Cuban your product needs just sell
needs to be a solution to a problem and
to me this is a rather large problem
with no solution yet yet
what's up counselor snitch no much just
chillin how are you post Peter Herman
I'm not well [ __ ] like I made all of my
friends watch it I like a lot of
one-on-one time with him yeah I did and
he was like just so nice to me like he
didn't just treat me like a PA and he
was like where'd you go to school what
you studied yeah did you know you went
to Yale oh my god of course he did I
know I didn't know I didn't know that
but I did you know he was just so nice
needs such great things to say about the
show like he just he said a term to me
yesterday that I can't stop thinking
about I told you this she did he said
that like the show it's just basically
like informed enthusiasm which is
exactly what you are well no one has
ever called us in forms before but I
totally get what he said yeah he's so
enthusiastic about him and younger but
we're also really informing about this
yet like you know I just don't think he
expected us to like know some
not only about younger but like Blue
Bloods SVU like his life Taylor Swift
you are informed enthusiastic we're
truly like a web of knowledge yeah in
the words of Amanda Bynes I got a
lifetime of knowledge I need to talk
about Amanda Bynes for a second because
you know what I watched actually I
started watching two days ago and then
finish last night hairspray because I
think it just was added to Netflix cuz I
remember looking for it once being like
I want to watch hairspray and it wasn't
on there and it's the like the revamp
which it's so funny because when they
redid it it was like a cheap knockoff of
the og hairspray now I consider bid like
Zac Efron hairspray like the inner spray
no it's so good it's so perfect you know
what I actually do want to see sometimes
I go hunting for hairspray live because
it was such a catastrophe and like I'd
love to relive it and it is nowhere to
be found
I actually think it's on a fire stick
because when I searched hairspray I saw
something come up really yeah I'm gonna
say like it might be on prime I and
that's how you know it's like a failure
because grease live was on Netflix was
it Makris live was a real failure Oh No
red red lines yeah grease live was
perfection
but I just want to talk about hairspray
because I don't think they realized it
at the time like how star-studded the
cast is like I think James Martinez
corny Collins might be one of the
greatest castings of all time and you
know what I realized I don't know if
James Marsden sings but I'm like 90%
sure the voice that they used for corny
Collins when he's saying was Michael
Buble which is like even more genius and
I tried to research it to you and then
something came over can you look into it
like something came up and then I got
like lazy and I couldn't say but it
didn't give me no results you know got
it and then what people don't even
realize about the cast Allison Janney is
penny Pingleton mom no I know
every star has so many like gems in it
also you would see on Spotify in Queen
Latifah in the listed music like when it
shows who's singing each song it would
say Michael Buble and whatever face Mars
him but I think it says James Martin
submissive James person like has an
amazing voice just Michael Buble which
Efron was so pure and young and like
really was the perfect link Larkin and I
just was watching the film like with so
much awe and like in my eyes and being
so pleased with like how it came out
and they just remember at the time
thinking when it came out like this is a
cheap knockoff yeah and you know what
ruins it
ooh let me think adele dazeem hmm Oh
time for real time yeah it's like soon
John Travolta will be cancelled for
being like a Kevin Spacey
and we're not gonna be able to enjoy the
movie anymore okay until John Travolta's
cancelled and I get like some firm proof
of misbehavior aside from just like him
being a weirdo for sure
he's definitely weird I [ __ ] love him
know I know and like that role for him
he was so great and he was like Edna
Turnblad is like such a great character
he did such a great thing with droll job
at the role but like a part of me knows
you know the truth and it's like our
days are numbered with hairspray I don't
know the truth so I'm just gonna be
ignorant and blind okay until like oh
and then Christopher Walken till Ronan
Farrow spells it out for me I don't know
the truth
totally so that's nice for me what did
you do yesterday oh my god I've been
going through yesterday without till we
drop
oh yeah I got some good stuff I have
some upcoming events affairs a wedding
in Kentucky but I've been like this has
been the longest week for me because I
thought I had an event on Tuesday which
was the Jonas Brothers album release
party and I know if I told the story
yesterday no yesterday we thought it was
last night I said the story yesterday no
but we said okay so basically I said
that we were going tonight that you were
going trying that it was a snitchy
affair and I gave away my cello yes so
to say I thought it was on Tuesday and
then I just checked my email and it
wasn't and then I'm like oh it's
Wednesday so then Ben also got invited
he's like but I think we got invited to
separate parties because mine's on
Thursday so after the toast yesterday I
looked at my email my okay in fact it
was Thursday so now it's like I have
thought that I was going to the same
event for three days straight and I
believe it's tonight yeah I don't want
to jinx it but I think it's tonight and
she got a plus two so I'm able to though
and I'm so excited I'm excited too
also someone just put an interesting
factoid in the feed did you know that
seaweeds little sister and hairspray
little Inez
yes it's played by one of the thank you
next writers Taylor works so well that
when I did more research on the cast on
the cast I saw her as little Inez and
her name sounded so familiar and I
didn't know why now I know that song ran
and tell that that was just one I'd like
the best scenes in the whole film two of
the songs that are in the soundtrack are
not from the original run until that
which is the best song and without love
which is literally the best song so it's
better than a bridge like my mother on a
diet
like a week that's only mondays only ice
cream never sundaes like a circle with
no center like adore mark do not injure
darling I'll be yours forever cuz I
never wanna be without love oh now
you've captured me love I surrender
happily such a good song such a great
movie I'm just glad we talked about it
cuz I feel like maybe at the time it
didn't get like the true praise it
deserves for being like a Broadway
moment mm-hmm and it was fantastic also
I watched the movie with like a pit in
my stomach because like part of me
really thinks like I was meant to play
Tracy Turnblad you were especially when
that movie came out I was like fat as
hell when that movie came out you were
12 when they alive
open ocean it was an open casting which
it's always been for Tracy Turnblad and
you did not pick up the baton like that
hurt you know that was always like she's
skipping the X Factor auditions in Long
Island yeah but you know what like I was
so glad that I did go and also like
honestly I feel as though being Tracy
Turnblad is sort of a curse except for
Ricki Lake but me she had like a huge
career where's Nikki Blonsky
I think she's a toaster somewhere okay
Nikki Blonsky I don't know where she is
but she has the most amazing Instagram
and I only know about it because I
follow a bunch of like housewife
comedians on Twitter and one of them is
obsessed with Nikki Blonsky whose name
is Brendan he does like the best
Housewives commentary but he's also but
weirdly obsessed with so many like when
Stefani he's obsessed with and he's also
obsessed with Nikki Blonsky and he live
he record some of her live and like
someone hacked her Instagram I think I
told the story before hacked her
Instagram it was like DMing people that
like she's friends with like calling
them mean things and she went on
Instagram live bawling her eyes out
saying how like this hacker is ruining
relationships where I'm like everyone
knows that it was hacked but they know
that it wasn't you saying she's so
dramatic her Instagram is wild she is
like a Tiffany Thornton we have to
follow her I'm adding her to the list
totally and then there was the other
girl who played in hairspray live Maddie
something nowhere to be found except now
she has a friendship with Doug Cameron
in Ariana Grande and you know that would
be enough for me
Diana even the hairspray live casting
was inspired Oh
Conlon penny Pingleton Doug Cameron as
amber who else Tracy
um
the girl Maddie she's none known oh well
um kristin chenoweth as Amber's mom
yes mrs. Von Tussle that was a great
casting Harris was just great I feel
like it can't be done badly no it kind
of jinx it but it can't be done badly
agreed well we have a big day because
obviously we have a vampire coming we
have to recap southern charm and Moroni
delivers the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast now I
have to say that I'm feeling like a
brand-new woman like you know the song
brand-new man by Brooks & Dunn that
Luke's in coments we done yes that's
about me because I am wearing a bra
today and I wear a bra every day and I
usually wear the same bra and when we
started working with third love I filled
up the quiz and I filled it out like
haphazardly and I got the brine it was
great but like it didn't really fit and
a week ago I did it again because I was
like let me pay attention to this quiz
and I paid attention and I really
answered the questions wholeheartedly
and I got robbed within I looked within
and I and then you know how sometimes
you like lie to yourself of course
there's no I'm not a 38 you know like no
ignite just don't like that so divide
yourself in the quiz like you're not
gonna get a bow that fits so I redid the
quiz a week ago and I was open with
myself and honest with myself and this
morning my phone rang and FedEx came
literally at 7:00 in the morning and I'm
wearing a bra it is a third love bra and
I have to say it is like I can't believe
I haven't been wearing this bra my whole
life my boobs aren't touching where's
like I get so much boob sweat and like
my spray tan like starts to turn crusty
because my boobs are like rubbing
against each other you have a nice
cleavage today leave it right it's her
love what's it called here JEP Latasha
vataj so the fit finder quiz is really
important you answer a few simple
questions to find your perfect fit in 60
seconds over 12 million women have taken
the quiz to date it's really fun and
takes less than a minute to complete and
I urge you not to lie to yourself there
is a hundred percent fit guarantee every
customer has 60 days to wear it wash it
put it to the test and if you don't love
it you can return it and third-level
wash it and donate to a woman in need I
love that third loves team of expert fit
stylists are dedicated to helping you
find your perfect fit third love knows
there's a perfect bra for everyone so
right now they're offering our listeners
15% off your first order go to third
love comm slash morning toast now to
find your perfect fit fitting bra and
get 15% off your first purchase
that's third love.com slash morning
toast for 15% off today there really is
a perfect bra for everyone and I feel
like for a while I thought there wasn't
for me no you just like because that's
what
once you did but it's like it's it's not
that like it's just physics and science
like it's really not that hard no look I
can't tell you like how I think my
posture is different today no it makes
the biggest difference I'm really happy
for you know that I am and I got to and
I use our code obviously I was like good
for you and I'm gonna order more I just
want to make sure that this like I
actually got the size right this time
that's exciting you have a whole new
lease on life I really do I'm wearing
what else oh they're amazing markers for
anyone to let us say you know you make
sure it's tight enough that it doesn't
require no bra today
no it my shirt is like literally so
[ __ ] tiny your braless wonder I
couldn't even split fit one in you know
I understand you know when it's like of
course I do
um anyways without further ado you hear
the stories that you need to know it we
actually had some cool and exciting
story starting with some random ass
drama between Hilary Duff's fiance and
dead oh you know I saw this and I was
just like obviously take the side of Zed
because I feel personally victimized by
Hilary Duff I saw this and I didn't get
a chance to read it yet so I look
forward to finding out the beef Matthew
koma says his friendship with former
longtime collaborators ed ended on very
bad turns singer-songwriter coma who was
engaged she younger star Hilary Duff
released a statement on Instagram about
how their partnership turned quote toxic
and caused them to go their separate
ways
quote in response to years of what
happened with you and Zedd I want to
finally be transparent about this it's a
really sad truth registers I mean like I
don't know if people for years have been
wondering what happened it's not like
one of the great wonders of the world
like only wonder what happened between
like one of the great wonders the
world's like what happened in that
elevator with Solange and jay-z not what
happened with Matthew yes one of my
wonders was who's Hilary Duff's fiancee
right and now I'm finding out how he
works but said yeah this does J work two
would say but he is in a field that
would require him to work I thought it
was more like in a boy band oh I didn't
get that I thought your mother gathered
on it saying he was a business man but
no no he's a musician
I saw times and I Instagram didn't know
every day it's a really sad truth
because I'm extremely proud of the work
he and I did together
unfortunately my good feelings towards
those songs have all but disappeared as
they were experienced alongside some
someone so toxic and self-serving that
it occupied the space where any
happiness could exist
kkoma wrote in the Apple Notes app quote
it's not that dramatic of a story and it
comes down to something simple continued
coma also a producer good to know
so Ruffalo's named shitty people suck
and when they're successful people are
afraid afraid
blow the whistle said hasn't commented
publicly or responded to comas claims
coma said he met dead whose real name is
Anton zolab ski before the German DJ
signed to interscope they work together
on what would become Zed's first two
singles spectrum and clarity and said
they met as equals why are you my
clarity
okay so if Matthew koma worked on
clarity I didn't realize but I guess
that makes me genius right it's a
[ __ ] best song ever it's it's a song
that like I'll never not here and just
wanna dance like no matter how tired I
am I'm at a funeral like I'm [ __ ]
fist pumping to that song no and it was
like transformative in the EDM space
because so many people like riffs off of
like what a meet she was doing this that
like clarity was its own thing yeah and
it was iconic so thinking I think Omaha
beyond most respect for you I mean I
know still said because I haven't heard
what he did yet quote from the beginning
his inferiority complex was made obvious
which seems so absurd because his
contributions were so wonderful and he
was a very talented producer back when
he was still involved in his productions
sure and the blows started small him
giving interviews in about the lyrics he
wrote I wrote every word at melody with
no mention of my name
not being paid for singing on spectrum
until two or three years of fighting for
a fee him producing a song I wrote
called suitcase for my album then not
allowing me to release it instead
insisting it was released as Zed with
another feature singer or I couldn't
have it I had to wait years to put out a
different version kkoma said that they
were at the finding together they wrote
find you together in Japan but claimed
Zedd didn't want comas vocals on the
record meanwhile Comus said he had
tucked his head out of keeping his
vocals on clarity and instead found
foxes who killed it did Zedd ultimately
want two Grammy for the collaboration
but koma claims Zedd didn't invite him
well there's no either no really like
what the behind the scenes like
arrangement was between them I see I see
this two ways I feel like I'm really
good at seeing both sides of a
perspective sometimes so I could see how
like definitely feels like Zedd could
feel like Matthew koma was thirsty like
wanting to get his voice out there sing
on every song and like just because you
wrote a song doesn't mean you're the
best person to sing it and a lot of
people like write songs that become
hugely successful by other people Dolly
Parton Whitney Houston I will always
love you um so I could definitely see
how like maybe Matthew koma was like
thirsty to put his voice on every song
instead was like no like let's think
bigger picture I can also see how Zedd
was maybe like thirsty and like stepped
on other people to get to where he is
like I see both I see both sides yeah I
see both sides if this is all true it is
very shitty um but also like I wasn't
there you know and the way people
perceive things isn't always as it
happened you know it might have felt the
tip is coming in cutting him out
meanwhile Zed's in another room having a
conversation you know maybe it's the
higher up
Center cutting them out right and it's
just like said he's telling us words so
I'm not taking a side here I don't
really give a [ __ ] because it sounds
like both of these people are equally
talented now that or that or they're not
and now that they're working separately
the proof will be in the pudding yeah
have you come on let's put out some box
you also I always have to think about
life like everything happens for a
reason so like now Matthew koma is at
the scoring relationship they just had a
baby like maybe it said had given him
proper accolades he never would have met
her laid up and given birth to their
beautiful child together so like life
works in weird ways you know maybe yes
be grateful though it said it did for
you cuz he gave you a whole other life
with Hilary Duff I'll up it's like it's
like re and Becca it always comes back
to are any bad guy like everyone could
say re was a bad guy and you bring back
a slide but like look a bad guy and the
happiest relationship up her life
lunching or on clothing line
thanks sorry sorry if you hadn't said re
re it's like that movie sliding doors I
never saw it but I know the message it's
a movie and it starts with what his pals
are getting on the train and the movie
has two stories they show what would
have happened if she missed the train
and what would have happened if she got
on the train and it's like when you what
is it like you like fart in Russia and
it like the wind shatters in America
what's that phrase you know it's like
that's a good thing it's like if you
open the door in Japan it causes an
earthquake in America you know that
thing you know whatever it's like
everything happens for a reason
Matthew comment so like just be happy
you're in a great place in your life now
now it's not a good time to like you
know digging up old bodies you know yeah
I am also looking for Matthew comas
music because he bar saying he has put
out pops and so I just want to UM to
find Bach because if the morning toast
haven't heard of it I don't know if I
would necessarily call it ABAB I feel
like I have a really wide range of
musical interests and okay well hold on
hold on maybe I spoke too soon yeah
he released parachute okay he he's taken
part in sorry For Party Rocking world
tour with LMFAO Sorry For Party Rocking
later toured with the band
Owl City in March he did a Bruce
Springsteen remix um then he did the
main vocals her song end of pretend I
don't know what the following spring he
toured Europe supporting Ellie Goulding
at alongside Charli XCX toured of
meaning what like open for or like was a
was a tour manager okay unclear was
Margo wait but in 2014
coma and DJ Hardwell released the single
dare you which is Oh ray
um I'm addressing it no it's not I kid I
know I know that's what I was thinking
great song by like I know you would also
there's also the new I'm pulling it up
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry okay other
songs include cheap sunglasses serotonin
I don't know those but I honestly don't
play it will get to monetize Oh honestly
dare he was a good enough song that like
maybe he is the talent maybe oh maybe
he's the Jennifer Hudson but then it's
like zebra at the middle did he yeah I
thought those two guys gray did Zen and
gray and then they shopped it around
yeah but like when someone has a hit
song that someone else wrote the artist
will always be written as a as one of
the songwriters like in if they were
just in the room so like just because
their names I'm doesn't mean they wrote
it someone told me that yeah
[Music]
that's a lot like the Lifehouse version
no it's so good if you actually Jerris
dare I say better than lighthouse
surgeon yeah it's whoa no way good like
us first of all jess is her live house
like really putting things into
perspective with their music for years
but second of all there's no song in the
world federate then like there's no song
that's ever made me feel the way that's
all song goes I understand
okay next step because we got to get
through we gotta get through the day
alec baldwin to be gross on Comedy
Central people are turning to Comedy
Central roasts as like career revamps as
it worked so well for Justin Bieber I do
actually think that Alec Baldwin is
beyond repair but let's say I don't
think so I mean look I feel like so torn
when it comes I feel the same way about
Alec bobbin that I do John Travolta look
I love their talent I love their work
and like I think they're a precious gem
and then like I know all the evil things
they do and I try to look past it yeah I
I hear that I'm in denial I don't think
that like Alec Baldwin hasn't been fully
cancelled yet like yeah there's people
like calling for it but he still got to
work and everyone's something about him
he's like on SNL no every week that's
what's crazy so he does actually doesn't
need to roast himself but by doing this
everyone will get out all the mean
terrible things that they think about
him and like I think he'll walk free you
know I really hope that they mention the
pig of it all when he called his like 13
year old daughter didn't grateful Alec
Baldwin removed yet again he could take
a punch this time around
at the least verbal kind when he sits
for a Comedy Central Roast this summer
The Comedy Central Roast of Alec Baldwin
will be taped in New York the taping
date and air date will be announced
later I feel like you could get invited
oh I think it should I I've been to a
roast once I went to the UM Bruce Willis
no Rob Lowe and like I didn't understand
any of it apparently had a sex tape with
like a ten year old I don't know okay
well you should work on that
quote getting roasted will be the
greatest honor of my lifetime besides
being a father a husband hosting SNL 17
times receiving Golden Globes and
working with Martin Scorsese that's
really funny
I love a good roast I've only ever
really seen Justin Bieber's so that's
the only framework that I have oh and
Joan Rivers that was really fun oh god I
never saw that yeah everyone was such an
[ __ ] and like why it's everyone
so mean and they're reading jokes
written by other people so it's like I
want the mat they're reading jokes
written by Matthew koma and like I want
to know who write that joke so wait when
I went to the Rob Lowe one you know they
had an Coulter there and she insisted on
writing her own jokes because like she
didn't want like I think the writers
like make her look stupid okay um and I
have to say like I've never in my life
been more uncomfortable like a broom was
just like not with her at all like
nobody was like and it's because like
the way that they're I think the worst
are set up it's like all the people who
are roasting are like on a team you know
and it's like they're like this unit
against the person and like she was just
chilly on her own Island like promoting
her book and right it's like the roast
of em cold no it turned into the roast
of em Coulter totally oh yeah and that's
also something out happens it's like
they all turn on like one of the
Roasters and it wasn't even about Justin
Bieber anymore is out like [ __ ] Pete
Davidson yeah yeah yeah yeah that that's
annoying that happens yeah the focus on
the beam you know what's so funny that I
was actually just thinking about when I
did when I went to that roast which was
in LA and I did like a comedy central
partnership or like I interviewed people
on the red carpet and like Jeff Ross
came and he was dressed his prints and
it was like right after Prince died and
I'm not like I didn't know anything
about prints and he was wearing all
purple and I'm like I love your outfit
like what are you wearing and he was
like talking about like Prince but he
was speaking really fast and I thought
he was talking about like a prince like
yeah you look royal like I was being so
dumb I hope nobody ever finds a video oh
my God look like the reference totally
went over my head and he was like I'm a
pimp
he's a Purple Rain I was I literally had
no idea what he was saying yeah that's
like a little that he's like the
roastmaster general yeah um that's above
my pay grade
yeah no no like I'm not that deep in
comedy I'm just a regular patron of the
comedy no totally it was definitely felt
out of place who do you thinks gonna be
there to roast Alec Baldwin definitely
some in the face yes uh his daughter
should do it a hundred percent Ireland
they should get also the man that he
punched in the street totally I mean
there's so many people like when you
think about it his long career like
offending people there are so many
people Meryl Streep yes I think they
could get her that's like when Martha
Stewart roasted Justin eat yes yes yes
that's a great call that there's so many
people who could like would love the
opportunity to do it cool I'm excited to
hear more about this and maybe I'll tune
in yeah
well how often do they do it I feel like
it's not every year no it's at most once
a year right because when was the last
one who was the last one Rob Lowe oh
yeah we're Bruce Willis yeah and I did
that like four years ago so yeah okay
next up yet prints only died like two
years ago or three years ago oh yeah
confusing next up Joe Jonas says Taylor
Swift's apology for blasting their
relationship quote felt nice have you
read this oh my god no Joe Jonas and
Taylor Swift have obviously moved on
from their relationship but that won't
stop them from looking back so when
Taylor Swift was on Ellen recently she
asked um Ellen like Ellen asked her like
something that maybe she regrets or
something and she was like cool probably
when I like put Joe Jonas on glass on
your show when she - uh she said that
was her most rebellious teenage act that
was too much that was too much she had
some weirdness I love a queen who sells
self-aware yes she said I was 18 yeah we
laugh about it now but that was mouthy
yeah some teenage stuff there I guess
she says yeah like we say like you know
what cuz I find the dynamic between the
Jonas Brothers and Taylor Swift to be so
interesting because there was so much
bad blood there are no both of them got
so famous off of that like if the
infamous 20 seconds phone call but now
like she's been doing so much press near
the Jonas Brothers they both did way no
tango they both did the boys she was on
that Graham Norton Show with sophie
Turner like they've been together so
much in the past like six months where
you think it would be weird but it's not
and now I guess we know why no it's like
the same way they said on the
documentary like when Nick Matt and I
lay his head exploded it's like burnin
up in the past that they can talk about
it and also like seeing cool but like
because it was so [ __ ] long ago it's
almost as if no one cares yes so Joe
heard her comments he said it did feel
nice it's something that I was probably
feeling pretty bad about when I was
younger but at the end of the day I've
moved on
I'm sure Taylor's moved on it feels nice
we're all friends it's all good we were
so young that is so great to hear like
because as someone who's caught between
a rock and a hard place being a Taylor
Swift stand and like a big Jonas
Brothers fan I don't know if I would say
I was a stand yet um you know it's been
really tough for me yeah and I think
this is also good for Taylor because
she's obviously not cool with like
really any of her exes but this makes
her look like a cooler not sure that
she's friends with Sophie and like I
think it's just like a good PR move for
everyone and actually like they were
dating for like a
I would agree and also how much levity
can you give to a middle school
relationship like where you've probably
never spoken just like hold two held
hands one time and they called a third
base no 1000% I was even talking with my
friends here talking about like college
relationships also faith you know
there's just so where she live in like a
fake world and everything is like going
to a party even when you go on a date
it's like it's all just something we're
gonna librarian like there's no but in
Hollywood like those types of
relationships are given like so much the
treated so real and we like we think of
it as like these huge moments where I
could affect it everyone's careers then
it's like at the end of the day it was
like a five-minute middle school
relationship yeah and it don't count it
doesn't count well speaking of middle
schoolers and and young people baby
sharp oh my god I'm sorry someone just
put in the comments at the song dare you
to move it's not by lifehouse it's by
Switchfoot justice for [ __ ] say no
say no but that's justice for sweet
truck because like now they're being
Matthew koma so true i hate when i
matthew Comaneci oh it's the worst baby
shark TV series based on viral song is
in the works at Nickelodeon genius the
Viacom kids brand has partnered with
smart studies pink fog to make the
social media sensation into a TV and
consumer products property oh my god I'm
sorry I brought props today I forgot
hold on give me one second they're in my
purse
oh okay bye watch out for the camera you
know I'm right here bye Chapman I guess
I'll read the story vikon's Nickelodeon
is partnered with the team behind
YouTube viral hit song baby shark to
develop an original preschool Annamarie
animated series based on it this is just
like so smart did you hear this
counselor snitch Viacom is developing
baby shark into an original series the
shark do-do-do-do-do baby shark dude
dude sorry I just realized that it was
Pride Month I made like no pride oh I
thought you were bringing out things no
I don't know like oh yeah that's perfect
yeah we just like need to pride up our
our sour set cuz like we are prideful
and we have like nothing to show for it
so yeah I brought it all the way from
Amazon and I wouldn't let myself forget
it here give me one and then maybe like
in the chair yeah cute and we'll just
keep it there all month lab right where
you want one for your snitch cam okay
I'll throw it that flew but let me
remember baby shark um I don't know what
no she what made me remember cuz like
five seconds ago I was like oh yeah it
was Margo and Olivia's idea I know what
made you remember I don't know
cool I don't know but Margo fiona is
easing the cellophane from the flags if
you don't mind it's annoying as hell the
sound yeah it feels as though no one
cares about baby sharks I'm trying to
tell you I'm not gonna lie really okay
why I just think this is so smart and
like you know what this might be
pertaining kids might be watching the
show no it's not it's pertinent for my
career it's like could something from
the internet goes to real TV maybe we're
next feel but like if this is the next
big thing but what say it gets greenlit
and it premieres in a year from now like
and you are having babies soon like it
could be the next like Barney yeah this
could be what your kids are watching and
singing so like how does that make you
feel it makes you feel good what TV show
do you identify with like as you're like
good um well primarily Hannah Montana no
but like I'm a baby yes Barney
I can't even think of another show like
Sesame Street is that elegies that was
listening I'm gonna really watch Sesame
Street look ever no I don't like to
recall watching it but it's like why did
not you know I was just stuck on Barney
yeah and then like the wb11 like don't
call me I'm Friday night I'm watching
the [ __ ] WB yeah totally the WB was
[ __ ] late no like our whole lives
were the WB more of us used to sit
around like yeah every night with our
ice cream bacon ice cream cones and we
would like try and like steal each
other's and watch the WB and like some
[ __ ] classic you know what's so weird
as we watched so much WB but we didn't
watch like the iconic shows on WB
Dawson's Creek or Buffy the Vampire
Slayer no we were busy watching maybe
it's me the hell the hell popular but by
the way WB is now see w it makes it
perfect it makes perfect sense yeah so
and we're still watching CW but I would
say as from my young adult life up until
like college the most transformative
show at Montana I won't say I was really
heavily influenced by that So Raven and
just like her comedic structure I feel
that for you you know what I feel as
though you child and waving vibes in
everyday life I remember the first time
I ever left so hard from a TV show like
silent laughed and it was at That's So
Raven I remember we wrote our cousin's
house in Florida we were watching and I
was laughing so hard and like I never
had left that
from something on TV before um yes also
a few more shows that people are minding
me Rugrats was definitely person into
our situation yep
cat dog we just watched it every Sunday
morning I just know I miss it but cat
dog was like trash we would watch it
like begrudgingly ya know it was because
there's the only thing on when you woke
up early on Saturday right and then
there was like spongebob Fairly
OddParents which is just the dumbest
show
I liked fairly oddparents quite a bit
yeah and so those were I guess the
cartoons and then obviously the OSI blah
blah blah that's like teenage when you
start doing drugs on TV it's we're in a
different category right or like
drinking you underage at 15 um but at
that time that the OSI was on so is
Hannah Montana and like that was the
bigger driver in my life ya know Hannah
Montana was amazing and there was a time
in in the world where Hannah Montana was
on Netflix bananas in pyjamas agreed
bananas in pyjamas I like that you know
when we always keep we keep talking
about this story about Disney's
launching your own streaming platform
and it's gonna be late I will subscribe
just for non Irish luck the Irish
[ __ ] model behavior cadet Kelly cadet
Kelly hitch perfect picture perfect
picture perfect smart house actually
every watch smart house recently and
it's just not what it used to be I first
of all now a 2019 it's like that house
couldn't do anything like it wasn't even
special it's like Siri and it was just
such low quality like film grade that I
watched every silly and just didn't do
the trick for me pepper Ann Braceface
those were the days it was Jessica Biel
movie when you wish upon a star oh yeah
no that was Katherine Heigl oh it wasn't
Jessica Biel what Jessica Biel movie was
to the deconvolution uh Sam in heaven
hmm maybe maybe that [ __ ] was ruined
right see that he's a John Travolta he
you know it's justice virgin until
innocent until proven guilty
come on I don't know anymore like I said
member I'm confused by Hollywood cuz I
thought we were doing innocent till
proven guilty because that's in the
court of law
but then with the YouTube movement we
believe women and we believe survivors
right but then with Michael Jackson
Hollywood stopped doing that so now I'm
just confused are we believing victims
are are we not I think we are I think we
are which is not it which is this which
isn't isn't innocent until proven guilty
no I know but like I thought we were
like not doing innocent proven guilty it
was everything that applies to sexual
assault yeah it's like if you're gonna
burglarize someone just
innocent until Pinellas with the Michael
Jackson documenting really threw a
wrench in all that all right so I was
just confused cuz I thought like
everyone in the world including
Hollywood was on the same page but now
Hollywood like it's just saying Michael
Jackson's great I nobody believed the
Ryan Seacrest victims either true oh
yeah yeah I guess it depends on the
person yeah and how much power and spite
you have okay did the final story a
little bit of more interest human
interest piece because Buber eats put
out a report called the cravings report
on Wednesday showing what people crave
on what days and what are the weirdest
things that people request so the top 10
most popular requests in the u.s. are
you know not that crazy
so I'm asking for people to hold the
onions tomatoes or cheese that's
probably you so I'm asking to lay it on
thick with extra sauce it's probably
your husband she spices and ranch the
uber eaters love ranch of course but
here are the top 10 weirdest requests
are you ready probably like a dog eating
something a piece of whoa it's right
there on the floor no no no he picked it
back up oh great it looks like the top
of a soda can
oh my god I got it let go let go do the
teman come on let his mom can't stop
eating it's like a dog with a bone he's
a good dog with a metal spring what the
[ __ ] okay top 10 weirdest requests
asking the driver to play a song while
they deliver the food what yep this is
my boyfriend's Valentine's gift it would
be amazing if you could play Africa by
toto when you deliver the donuts you
don't have to play the whole thing
really just the core number 2 living for
the sauce quote this is our unique but I
like to dip my sandwiches very heavily
in rinchen honey mustard very very very
heavily I just live for the sauce I hate
dry food can I please have six dipping
sides of ranch and six dipping sides of
honey mustard for my sandwich oh my god
that is hysterical wait number three
deconstructed sandwich please send all
sandwich parts separately I will put
together myself I by the way that I kind
of understand but it's just funny what's
funny about it is the way that people
write it and like explain themselves
like I just live for softness like
everyone's like please do this insane
thing yeah for some like it hot we like
our food extremely spicy
got a $20 tip for everyone if you make
the spaghetti in lasagna spicy ish
and say it one that you deliver the food
you know so I know it's real
thanks guys if I go weird five is please
also send 13 containers of grande
stressing I've got six
can you leave instructions for me
instead do you remember with each bite
and daydreaming about beach parties in
Goa of that person's like on drugs yeah
seven bacon extra extra extra crispy if
you try to bend the bacon and it breaks
then it is perfect just short of burn is
another good way to describe it
thank you in advance for your attention
to detail regarding the cooking of the
bacon it is the most important part of
the meal so please take my request
seriously but that I also understand
yeah a your tacos are so good returning
customer can you please have the
spiciest hot sauce you have on it I like
it spicy so don't be afraid to add it is
it the green spice salsa but Theo is
feeling prideful he is totally gay I
know it's so proud how do you how does
this make you feel feel proud oh it does
okay you can have one actually no that's
disrespect just so but I feel as though
when I write requests for the driver or
do your restaurant it's like nobody
reads it or it's like I feel as though
it has to be like two words or else it
won't they won't understand it yeah also
and it's like okay nobody at the
restaurant reads it but people that
Buber corporate or reading it I'm better
sex so Madison like the other day I
asked for extra mustard and then said I
got no mustard Wow
hurtful that's just someone I shouldn't
I said nothing and got my two packets of
my sweats I can't believe how like
special of a moment this is I wish
people if you're watching the podcast
like please turn into the YouTube stream
right now because do I think he's coming
out I think he's an icon he's out I love
you I love you I love his love I get it
getting this here so get away not really
take these legs
precious yeah like I couldn't find an
Amazon order that just had like five I
didn't need twelve you know okay let's
recap we're honi
we're getting distracted yeah put your
flags away okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry matter what you said in front of
the country give them to me okay get
back to work if I'm sorry I'm sorry
everyone sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry roni
okay where holy was great what happened
LuAnn is like next-level out of control
narcissist next week looks insane I hate
when I watch an episode I'm like oh I
can't I just wanna watch it next week no
I hate when i watch an episode and I
just want to watch next week I also hate
when I watch an episode in like I want
to like put my hands too
television and choke someone and that's
how I felt about LuAnn yeah but it was
overall a really good episode
I'm loving sewing is she's so clear how
are these women not hungover no by the
way at when they all woke up the next
morning and I thought they were gonna
make like the biggest deal ever out of
Sonja like being in the hospital with
the but she was like I feel great and
like nobody thought anything of it yeah
but also when it comes down to it like
she had five drinks she really just
hadn't he hadn't eaten and I think it
was just a case of poor planning I've
been in that city I don't think that she
was on pills no and I don't think that
she has a drinking problem and when she
was like I've gone to the doctor I've
gotten all the tests like it's a
chemical thing I don't think she has a
drinking problem either but LuAnn being
like so pain in the words of Peter
Herman patronizing being like I'm gonna
go to a meeting I think you should come
like yeah please please no I hate one
like especially with LuAnn like she it's
amazing that she's sober and I think
anyone who's intending to live soberly
is stronger than me but she like wheeled
it around like you're better than
everyone would like no offense like you
literally just like relapse so week ago
like please relax right and that's the
thing and at last season and the reunion
we watched it all knowing she went back
to rehab right and then this season now
we're watching it knowing that she ends
back up in prison and so she used to
looks like a colossal hypocrite ya know
and I was making a lot of excuses for
her at the reunion that she missed being
like they're all speaking of her so you
know it like speaking so poorly of her
and you know she's being open about her
you know relapse and now I'm just kind
of like wishing I didn't do that because
she's being so hypocritical ya know but
we weren't all there we were unlike
Bethenny you know everyone deserves
especially while you're down like that's
when you need your friends and you know
addiction and alcoholism it's not just
like a one-stop shop you haven't you're
cured like it's a process so I think
we're all giving her that space to like
figure it out but now like she's just
it's just coming off now so hypocritical
like hey if she relapses like that's
human nature that's fine but like
knowing the way she talks to other women
when she's doing well right it's like
you would be kicking you while you're
down right no likes everybody everyone
deserves to be like taking care of when
they're down but how you act when you
come back like says so much about you
and like it's not saying good things
know how she is when she's on top like
okay so we'll treat you the way you
treat the people on the bottom while
you're
top yeah and you know what's so
interesting it's like they literally in
the middle of the episode like fired
Barbara yeah they were like this group
is not for her I mean she can't handle
Ramona like excluding her and like
definitely being mean but like not the
biggest deal in the world like this show
is not for her it was really strange
it's like she just gave up yeah also in
page six I read yesterday that her home
is in foreclosure I read that too so I
what it was like bet that he decided in
that moment in that interview like she
was firing Barbara yeah I mean it was
good someone just had to had to do it
her blind loyalty is completely
uninteresting and I just don't care
enough about her personally to like look
past it agree because we didn't know
anything we never even saw her house
like we ever met her family like I
didn't know since they had a sister I
did because she's to be on a show and
that oh really service it Tinsley was on
the show back in the day and it
resurfaces in the toaster screw path and
I watch a pilot like oh and her sisters
in it yeah - her sister's really cute
has great legs and I loved those boots
yeah and I just love a sister moment
yeah and she was being a good sister
like just giving good advice and the
Bethany Tinsley friendship which is
something that's in Ohio you know it's
so weird when they woke up in the same
bed I was like shipped to my mother
[ __ ] quarter it's like a friendship I
did not actually I knew that I needed
like because they're both just like
normal great girls and it also shows how
and why Bethany and Carol were so close
in the first place because it's like
they're similar you know they have like
yet went south but like at one point
they were the best of friends and if if
Tinsley can be great friends with Carol
that would also mean she would be a good
friend for Bethany but it also makes me
think like how [ __ ] flaky is Tinsley
like she was a ride-or-die for Carol
like took that friendship to the very
end killed the relationship with Bethany
like she was really like very much like
in lesser Union I hated Tinsley so much
I go I disagree I think she's gone about
in such a normal way she was best
friends with Carol she defended her best
friend but even while she was like
riding for Carol her and Bethany always
had a decent relationship like when
Bethenny was asking her all this stuff
about Scott like a 13 and last season I
just thought it was really nice they've
always been like cordial the the fight
with Carol never permeated into Bethany
intensely and now this season it is now
like episode 10 and they're really
budding up it wasn't like she jumped
[ __ ] like they'd be like you can't be
like a loyal friend like her and I care
friends I think that their friendship
has changed because of the Scot stuff
like I think they were so close because
they were four so yeah and that just
changes and so now she's closer with
doesn't it actually seems really natural
to me no I won't I don't agree that it
seems natural but it just seems so odd
and when they woke up in the same bed
I'm like that is weird like I don't know
the name Carole used to sleep in the
same bed and then Tinsley and Carole you
think they slept together I think they
um they just were hanging out hungover
together they didn't seem like they woke
up together yeah I also hate those
scenes in the bed like I'm just like
everyone's breath must be terrible oh my
god I know and like they really need to
like stage like I don't want the show to
be scripted at all but I don't need to
see Ramona and Sonja waking up like in
real time like I would like to see them
fake waking up here's the thing I don't
think it's even in real time like I
think at that point everyone had like
brush their teeth and like I think
Tinsley walked into Bethenny's room I
don't think that they slept together
okay that would be interesting though
yeah so I don't know and honestly this
is like that this the season of house
why I said that we've been waiting for
these are the moments like everything up
until then was up until this has been
pretty easy by the way I went on Sonja
Morgan New York web site last night
because I just Sonya looks so cute and
every time she wears something that I
could love in me this year she goes
thinks it was $40 you thought that she
would be selling it on Sonja Morgan New
York she wasn't but the website was
premium as hell and I know it's like
stuff from Target and ASOS just marked
up because it has so many Morgan's name
on it now but I'm okay with that I know
like I'm okay with it too and like I
don't know why no me neither they're
being Matthew koma totally so I love I
love Sonja
every time she speaks she's like so
clear she makes great points she's
really like the perfect housewife
because she doesn't not afraid to
embarrass herself right and I I don't
know if maybe I'm just like a Sonia
apologist and if any of the other ladies
got so wasted and fell in their face
like Dorinda like what I have been like
she's an alcoholic but I don't know
something about Sonia like just if she's
it's different she's like so normal when
she's sober and she really doesn't drink
anymore like in the beginning I would
say frisky season she definitely had a
problem she wasn't anywhere and not
getting wasted and then she didn't drink
forever and she like learned how to
moderate and she went a little overboard
like I just don't think it's crazy but
it's she like she said it's always the
welcome drinks that get you it's true
look who drinks wrong know when you're
on a plane like they don't have good
enough snacky oh yeah and the rum
Ramona's man is cute yes I'm in there
Bethenny was trying to set up Tinsley
with was also really also really cute
she was being really stupid
that's she was being an actual father I
know and they didn't like her dress
maybe they're nice made her look like a
five-year-old yeah and then when
Bethenny was pointing out like the girl
in the polka dots like she looks like a
six-year-old she really was being a sick
all-around six-year-old yeah um and I
just I won't love for tensley like it's
time you know it's definitely time but
like she needs to grow up a little bit
to be in like an adult relationship and
like that's what she's missing yeah yeah
but I feel as though this is her grown
like I don't think she's gonna change
she needs just a little more confidence
you don't think like her whole shtick is
cute and like when she met Scott and
they were I mean on that day on that
date like she was being a six-year-old
but she was being really cute yeah II
thought it was cute I thought I think
it's not everyone is gonna think the
six-year-olds Jake is cute
no first she's immediately like like
shortening the pool of people who would
be eligible for Polly but there's a lid
for every pot yes and I think she just
needs to get her like confidence in her
swagger back and if she can talk to
Peter Herman because now that he knows
what swagger is yeah he can help her
find it within herself
agreed um and then oh southern charm
honestly it was one of the more boring
episodes and I watched it like on my
phone really yeah I was working on our
camp toast website like I was doing a
million other things so son Squarespace
you know of getting marketing together
we just love squares me we love
Squarespace because they have domains
websites online store its marketing
tools all in ones all in one excuse me
you could say more sell more stand out
in any inbox with Squarespace email
campaigns their all-in-one platform
makes it easy to unify your brand voice
from your homepage to your emails with
consistent content from website to email
you can create a beautiful website to
turn your cool idea into a new website
showcase your work blog or publish
content sell products or services of all
kinds promote your physical or online
business and now they also have the
ability of email campaigns it's just a
great service that we actually use here
at the toast headquarters
so check out squarespace.com slash toast
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch use the offer code toast to
save 10% of your first purchase of a
website or domain again that
squarespace.com slash toast and if you
use code toast
you will save 10% off your first
purchase at the website or domain love
it well when you were mine Squarespace
here's what you missed on seven times no
I mean I watch it was just like so
stupid and boring those tree houses I
was like we're really they look too cute
but it's like they're why was the wine
so bad also why I kept them planning a
vineyard tasting I mean no I think
that's like mature of her like to do
something for
I mean she obviously wanted to go to B
Street houses she obviously spends a lot
of time on Pinterest yeah and to do
something for the girls what else is
there to do there okay but like they
were all coming for him like I
definitely feel like they're scraping
the bottom of the barrel for something
to talk about but it's true
like how much she's going through a lot
for sure in comparison to everyone else
but like in comparison to the world like
it's not that big of a deal and like get
your [ __ ] together and show up on time a
hundred percent there was a lot going on
that I won't talk about first of all I
feel as though there are things that
don't get said you know for example like
the the judge might see your behavior on
the show yeah and it might affect your
custody like they don't really like say
that outright okay but if that's what
they're saying it's like stop talking
about Catherine being m.i.a agree or the
one making it a story like they're
calling her and she's not answering like
what are they gonna do second it's
giving me sort of LuAnn vibes or it's
like he's been through so much and we're
all gonna help you but how you act when
you're doing okay yeah it's like now you
now you're gonna be treated like
everyone else like that's the prize
Jorma it's a level playing field
congratulations ma'am is out of the
woods like so like I understood that and
you know I'm a Catherine I wouldn't even
say apologist because she has nothing
I'm a Catherine stand but I felt the
girls and I feel sometimes when you're
someone's friend like it's so easy as
your shitty friend but it's easy when
you just blow past everything they do
wrong you don't really care you're not
gonna call them out because you know at
the end of that you go home to your life
and you don't care what happens when
you're not together but to call someone
like be the you know unpopular person is
really a nice thing to do you know I
felt as though they were actually being
good friends where it's like we care
about you we want to make sure you're
doing well I thought Naomi was coming
from a good place
I thought Danny was being a little nuts
I think Danny was being harsh but that I
think it's because Danny cares about
Catherine then Danny she's the most and
Danny's seen and he has been with her at
her worst so now when Catherine's had
her best driving Rolls Royce like pick
me up no totally like where the perks
there all the time pick me up and I do I
know people are like it's not like you
don't do this to get stuff in return but
but on I mean in general you shouldn't
do something so that when they're at
their best you get a ride in a Rolls
Royce but like your friends should want
to do that but we shouldn't expect it it
should just happen no but like and then
expect it yeah I have to say the haircut
that Chelsea gave Shep was excellent her
craft is wonderful Madison's craft is
like on the down low when Patricia was
like Madison
she was Jeffrey occupy I can't deal with
patrician and I'm not I like Madison I
don't care enough to like like that
whole storyline the entire episode last
week was just like human medicine and
medicine to know a student could you
like I don't care every time they film
something about Austin and Madison like
I'm on my phone scrolling yeah like I'm
really more invested in the girl
storyline than the boys know same and
I'm just I'm I love the girls I love
their friendship and even though there
was drama like it's not it's interesting
but it's not detrimental and it's just
good you know yeah and I just like want
to live in allies this plantation or
whatever it was called well so they are
restating the show and they're trying
til I go hard get her in through the
back door and it's interesting her life
is clearly interesting she is a quite
interesting life but her as a person is
not like I don't enjoy you should assess
things that I'd make me cringe but like
I want to see more of her house agree
when she's on the show like being filmed
I don't like her in her interviews I do
I feel like she's more introspective and
more mature that stuff with the plane
was insane oh my god totally like what
that's so crazy no I know and I thought
she was like definitely lying about it
but then they had the news articles
approve it yeah no I didn't think she
was lying but I was like it was just so
crazy ya know it was I didn't see that
coming it was ship or they mean either
like when you cheat death like that's
truly like I was it may be her in the
car I thought she was there enough I
said they got on the plane there's like
emergency landing whatever and ended up
okay
yeah no Joan really cheating death yeah
so crazy that's like shakes you to the
core no totally is he gonna live with
this that he's Jimmy he's just looking
over all at Wednesday night is now a
great night on Bravo it is and it's like
they ease you into it cuz there's
nothing on Mondays anymore and then
Tuesdays you just get Beverly Hills and
it's like enough time to just soak it in
nothing else and then Wednesdays they
double you up I'm enjoying the Bravo
schedule right now when it was excuse me
have to sneeze everything on a Monday
lessee yeah like that was really tough
yeah I agree
also speaking of Bravo they filmed
dinner
Beverly Hills Romanian mom Lisa
Vanderpump was not there Lisa Vanderpump
was not there America she looked
incredible oh I would love to hear your
thoughts because people are like up and
arms freaking out about your wreaths
clips I
we hold on so she was on her Instagram I
thought she's tagged in it for sure he
just won't don't eat the pride flag
alone and honestly oh she wear a lot of
clips I think it's kind of cool and cute
I can only imagine the headache Doreen
has with that high pony and then 7000
clips in her hair but whatever I love
her like I like it I think it's cool she
and she different yeah like and she's
very like editorial about the way that
she looks like yeah her ex are in and
she's taking it to the next level yeah
um I think it's cool and I love a high
pony and I think it's cool to meet you I
don't mind if people are like up in arms
I don't you read yeah I think it's
cooler than the bobby pins right but
everyone's like I guess people she gave
a [ __ ] for last year for a bobby pin so
now she came back with an even bigger
bettors yeah and um that's her tagline
like I wear a lot of hats oh yeah a lot
of hair like this is a full circle I'm
at for it no I it's it's self awareness
at its finest yeah I like it I'm like a
little disappointed Camille does show up
at the Reunion
Andy comment said on his Instagram live
and Lisa Vanderpump okay so what he said
I think he like gave a clue he said Lisa
Vanderpump is not at the reunion right
now and Andy Anderson Cooper was on like
a FaceTime live with him and he was like
oh but was she there at all so either
she comes and leaves or she does a
separate like watch repens lifestyle
one-on-one which she definitely doesn't
comes and leaves like only comes to get
shot on and then like not talking about
anything i'll yeah she'll probably do
one one-on-one I owe you $10 cuz I said
she wasn't gonna go yeah I think it was
50 but whatever was it I can't remember
someone's on the phone someone will keep
us it's we'll call it even did assign it
to a charity
someone will keep us accountable just
like the great pasta debate of 2019 some
will keep is gonna do anything just like
Teddy Mellencamp the one pasta would
Teddy its pasta no but someone did a
whole member when we were fighting over
the pasta story and you said I was
talking too long and then I said your
story was longer oh yeah when someone
nighttime I was all try everything
yours is longer and argument that we had
longer than was longer than most not
surprising to me at all nothing I just
said sir president um no thank you for
asking
I I appreciate the opportunity and I
another say okay well without further
ado we had vampire time
we're gonna take a quick break Jason
tardik will be out here we're taking
your questions from Instagram for Jason
if you're watching live on the YouTube
stream feel free to drop a comment there
as well we will be right back so go get
a snack
take a piss get a third love bra and
stay tuned
you
okay
I'm feeling very spooky cuz we are back
with the one that only the vampire Jason
taught it now I'm so excited to see you
your hair looks amazing thank you
now I'm not getting my rights at all and
I'm not gonna give vampire vibe so can
you good for us are you a vampire or not
I don't tell you why we think you are so
I can confirm that I'm actually not but
I was trying to hide it with my style
today you know you look very odd vampire
carry on vampires I'm gonna tell you one
quick funny story so when you're on The
Bachelor I had a one-on-one date that I
thought was one of the weirdest
one-on-one dates in the history of The
Bachelorette and we went to Edgar Tyler
Poe and all sudden I'm kissing Becca in
uh in a tombstone and then we went to
like it was like a bloody vampire
perfect vampire okay so I didn't realize
I look like a man but I think about the
bachelor you know know things about
yourself it wasn't I think your hair
grew because you can't get a haircut
while you're on The Bachelor right
exactly
towards the end so actually they watch
back to season I was on strikes I like
have a whole problem with the franchise
um but I tuned in because everyone was
like Jason so great okay let me see what
Jason's all about and I tuned in and I
was like okay he's great but like what's
with the vampire hair and it wasn't your
fault because you can't cut your hair in
the vampire and it started to curl
behind your ears and I was like someone
get the sky and so did make shoes that
date for you because you look like a
vampire or you just also happen to like
at the funny thing about it I never my
life dialogues like a vampire it's
Buffalo hockey here it's called flow but
there's three months after the show I'm
like oh my god those sons of [ __ ] way
that a vampire so you know vampires are
the thing they're hot so it's a
compliment for sure oh they did like so
big Twilight and we had two guys are
usually Edward or Team Jacob Edward you
look today like you would be ten you
can't be a vampire your chance to deal
with your girlfriend kaylynn I live in
Nashville it's been 48 hours it moved in
last weekend and we want the O here
specifically for you because we know
that you left you
home and your new dog to come in our
shower and we appreciate you for
respecting the hell out of us so we
wanted Theo to be here just so you could
experience what it's like to be a new
doctor it's amazing what tips do you
have um potty trained the dog it's Theo
is the worst dog ever but all he could
do is pee outside and it's the only
thing that matters like he can jump on
my furniture he could sue me whenever on
auto care does he doesn't be at my house
until ramens actually potty-trained
already he's just over a year old he's
had two accidents in the last two days
but he's pretty but you moved in with
Caitlin so I moved in with Kayla thank
you that Charette did you think you
would find like chill of with another
bachelor nation person or you thought
you would like just like settle down
with a an average citizen just kidding
we're an interesting group I didn't know
what to expect going into the whole
thing and coming out of it I certainly
didn't know what to expect but on that
venture you don't have your phone you
don't have TV no internet no friends no
family I've always been so busy with
work so it's the first time I could like
really self reflect and like dig into
myself no I got out of the show off of
disappoint it didn't work out with Becca
I told everyone close to me go I
guarantee you I'm gonna serious
relationship within a year cuz I felt
like so like vulnerable and opening all
my feelings yes I never done as a closed
box book right so I didn't know if we'd
be in the franchise outside the
franchise
I love the franchise I love what they've
done and I'm so fortunate from going on
the show because I didn't meet cable
yeah sure she was responded to my VM a
few the blue checkmark is that how it
all popped off vADM no so actually we
met as well she we message each other
cuz she wanted to do podcast right that
was in the summer and we just like
couldn't go that's like I can't make it
happen we just do a phone call
she's like no all by podcasts or in
person yeah and so it's funny how things
work out because in the summer though
the worst that way and it was late fall
and those first time we met in person on
her podcast in Seattle and she was
single and she well yes she was single
at the time no they hadn't announced
they had announced their breakup
cuz she was single time that is so yeah
yeah but we just met when I was friend
zoned for a while I got my friends on
for a while and I broke that friend zone
down good for you
have you watched her season of The
Bachelorette never watch it and I never
once was I've heard a lot about he was
it she is such a great gal yes Rob's in
the beginning with that whole double
battle which is why I came out so if you
had watched her season like you probably
have a crush on her already an existing
crush yeah she's a great season
I enjoyed it great I'm glad that she's
not gonna go back I think a lot of
people were upset because they were
looking forward to seeing you on
paradise and now since you're a taken
man you're a live-in boyfriend people
are not gonna see you my paradise so
were you upset about that was I upset
about not being a parent not at all
actually there's an interview September
and iheartradio fest and I think it was
Lauren Zima and I said I hope that I'm
not even in the predicament to go on
paradise because I'm that serious about
finding someone so you can look at it
back then and I found someone so I love
paradise I can't wait to watch this
summer right yeah my boy Blake on there
to fascias they're having [ __ ]
awesome I did a show in Orange County
and I'm drinking mean great first-person
wine Taoiseach
like what you just DME are gonna give me
a free ticket so now that you're a
bachelor Paradise spectator just like
the rest of us who are your couple
predictions who do you ship in advance
especially in terms of your friend Blake
yeah so Blake I've been coaching Blake I
feel like four months now okay things
not to do but I think that him and
Hannah would be great together meet you
I think him and Hannah would be great if
it can't be our sister we tried so hard
to set her up with him at stagecoach and
he was just like she's a little flaky
like always being like I'm going it was
just like I don't think was a match on
either and me neither but friendship for
sure you know who else I really wanted
to find happiness is wills
yes wills is a great guy he's from LA he
was really stylish
news I'm Becca C's it's super stylish
guy yeah big sweet I know he'll be on
Debbie Corki
she's great so I really hope she finds
happiness throw away and then I heard
rumors that don't know if it's true
clay Harbor may be going on cuz they
broke up
any man Angela broke up so sad and I
don't know if he is are going I don't
know if he's not but I just know he's a
really good guy so I'd like to see a
good story for him okay well I have a
question for you because doing Kaitlyn
I've been together now what for like six
months yeah and you were doing
long-distance yes and now I mean you've
only lived with her for a day and you
came to New York um but how do you feel
like that's gonna change elevate are we
gonna see a televised wedding soon the
only if you marry one as we tell us the
only thing she said about a wedding that
she was certain she wanted was that
Chris Harrison would marry s flux that
is like the non-negotiable her and Chris
are really good friends
chris is an awesome guy I didn't get to
know him too well on the show but after
the show I got to hang out with him and
do some events he is he's obviously
likable out of the show and he's 10 20
times more likeable off the show just a
great guy so for her not negotiable
I agree Chris Harrison's gonna marry us
but would you be open to a televised
sweating an ABC special I'm ready for
marriage black oh I'm ready for me I'm
30 you ready yes I'm 30 I've experienced
a lot I've moved four times with my job
I've had serious relationships in which
I got hurt serious relationships in
which I had to be the one to break I
just seen all angles on a damn reality
show to find love yeah and I feel like a
person well speaking of your job people
want to know now that you're moving are
you moving with your job or starting a
new job what is your job so that is a
great question I'm in corporate banking
I've been in corporate banking for nine
years
it's kind of a loaded question but so in
life you got to make business decisions
and personal decisions right then
sometimes there's a synergy of the two
I'm gonna be upfront and honest nine
years corporate banking and being an
accounting finance seven promotions for
relocations I don't say that to pump my
chest I say it's put in perspective we
are in a great world right now Caitlyn
has a high school degree and from a
business decision it made much more
sense for me to move there because of
the sex success she has in her wine
label and her scrunchies itself so I'm
helping out with all the finances of
each of those businesses and in addition
I have a few things going on myself I
also own two businesses I don't really
speak about but one's a real estate
lending business
another one is a seed stage investing
company and a big thing I'm working on
now is
doing a company called restart because
my life was all about detours and taking
restarts and helping people that are
having certain life circumstances and
going through a series to kind of help
them restart where they're at so if
there's anyone listening and watching if
you have a situation when it's
financially personally a relationship
like navigation email restart adjacent
are calm and we're getting a really fun
series together so yeah all of your life
experiences you'll be doing better
entrepreneurial but chef finance-related
are you watching The Bachelor this The
Bachelor yeah are you enjoying we're
actually not watching the season just
because we're on strike where it started
as a strike and now I'm just enjoying
the free time but I've heard it's a
great season and she seems like a great
girl and she has fabulous style so I
liked her when they chose her if we
don't want to go there we don't have to
because when your abstract you know okay
I'm on strike just because I think that
they take advantage of our time and it's
like minimum two hours a week with just
like actual ten minutes of like real
substance of like people falling in love
and I just like can't deal with all like
the hype and like I just it's literally
a full-time job to watch a batch right
and then also recap it it's just like
the it's like by Wednesday for me the
bachelors over and it's like the weeks
have over sure I understand you know
okay yeah and each episode is like
coming up coming up and then just
previously plike it's never there's not
enough substance and it just feels like
taking advantage of our time our
advertiser space and it's it's really
frustrating will definitely watch
bachelor in paradise oh yeah it's a
great job it's just like it was just
becoming too much and all the colors I
guess the coltan hype was at the end of
thing worth the hype but you know
because there actually was a lot of
drama you know and the fence it really
was a dramatic episode we were freaking
out we also didn't know what was gonna
happen
what out that's what out there isn't
hype to tell the story start to pump
rules it's an hour and they fill that
hour with good [ __ ] yeah okay so just
compared like when you're doing cost
analysis and all gallery shows it's just
too much time it's like summertime
Monday's still house 50%
that's good feedback yeah so about this
season I think it's fantastic I think so
we saw a hand after the final rose and
she I'm just gonna be she was a little
bit of a disarray right she is she
you didn't really know what she was
doing and I think people were starting
to question what's gonna happen how's
this he's gonna be and I think she has
blown all those expectations away I
think if you guys really enjoyed Kaitlyn
on her season which I have a watch by
don't Kaitlyn as a person I think you
would enjoy Hannah because she's candid
transparent block puts on table takes
control of situations right and I mean
see that she's doing that's a great
comparison because what I loved about
Kaitlyn's season is you can always tell
when there's a bachelor or bachelorette
who just does what the producers tell
her to do and it's like so annoying and
no Kaitlyn like in the middle of day we
like it sorry you know I'm not feeling
you bye and that's the best day but that
Trek cuz that doesn't waste time so if
you had us the same way I mean I just
think it's a little late for me but I
and I like ten and when they chose her I
was on her team I'm just I'm happy for
her I'm watching from the sidelines just
like a please shading and help she's
doing great I think always probably the
big difference in her at Kaitlyn has
that just that quick yeah wait that is
just I'm in my opinion I've never met
anybody that's as quick and fast in
Woody's case but uh in summary and I
think it's doing a great job so who do
you think will be the next Bachelor
based on her crop so I was on Strahan
and Sarah the other day and I said it
kinda understand bygones I'm as straight
as an arrow
but this Tyler C guy is a freakin stud
and if you're not watching the show go
look about Jesus stuff she's what would
you agree he's well-spoken he's well put
together he's a stud had to tow so far I
haven't seen a flaw
[ __ ] in the army so you don't think
he's gonna be the man for her I think
he's gonna be up there I don't know if
he'll win or not
I haven't read spoilers but I just think
like we're looking in this group when I
see that guy I'm like that guy would
make a great Bachelorette that's her so
similar this guy Pete and then there's
one other guy Mike Johnson I call Mike
Johnson the John snow of the season he
like sticks up for the bullies and he's
a big well-spoken guy and I'm a big Mike
Johnson fan when you see when you were
on the season with Becca and you made a
top three right yeah did you think you
were gonna win like you did you know she
had
our connections with other people Alvia
I was the underdog from the minute I
blocked out of that limo and we had
really deep conversations and a good
connection and I think I heard I just
respect the hell out of each other and
her Garrett and I have such a good
relationship to this day and we'll
continue that but I'll be honest I
thought towards the end I'm like I just
felt like I was my like it wasn't I
wasn't my connection wasn't as strong as
the other guys well I thought ours was
strong you can kind of read when your
ingredients you can kind of read you
know physical behavior and things like
that and I'm like something was just a
little off got it yeah so are you still
friendly with Colton Oh big time didn't
Cassie I thought yeah so what so I
talked to Colton at least once a week
him and Cassie we Kaitlin and I had a
podcast with them in Aspen
we were up with them to like 4:00 in the
morning hanging out Cassie is awesome
she was drinking like caramel salt
flavored whiskey's just awesome and what
the you know the realest things were
kind of both going through this
interesting situation that met a more
magnified level you know Kaitlyn was
engaged and now her and I are together
so everyone has an opinion on that and
Colton's situation was kind of funky
with the fence jump in the way it ended
and cassia Colton people are questioning
their compatibility so between the four
of us we were going through a lot it was
just an open discussion and it was it
was it was great I think they're awesome
together whether that shows are not via
Instagram or via all these other the
other forums I really do think they're
good together
yeah well how do you deal with that
because maturation is [ __ ] insane and
people feel really strong ways about the
Caitlin Sean the Caitlin Jason and even
when we just were posting that you were
coming there people are like it's so
many impassioned questions sure how do
you kind of deal with that because it's
on such a big level of like the Twitter
responses in the Instagram comments and
people get really mean really easily
yeah so I think at an early stage when
you go on the show you get off you
realize the magnitude of bachelor nation
and that's where that is a strong group
that's like a mafia yeah I mean they
stick together and they're opinionated
as they should be and they they kind of
bounce back a lot of ideas and you hear
all the feedback so I became I come you
become a little numb to it
have to and what you really want to do
is what I do is like the people I value
that most I try and get opinions from
them to really guide me but you know
what is the point of dwelling I care who
you are I the vast nation if you're
actor/actress if you're doing if you're
a banker and Buffalo every person you
date has a past and I don't understand
it's okay to have a bath it's great that
we all we've learned from our past let's
make this who we are today
so for me it doesn't bother me at all
you know candidly I've never never met
Shaun so I I don't know and you know
everyone has a past
I have access yeah but I hope this
world's better than this is on tacky
Corey but this world's a better place
when people are happier so I hope
everyone whatever way it is they find
their happiness I hope he does too I've
never met him but you know well we have
a question that I think is a really nice
note to end on what are you most looking
forward to in the future like coming up
in your life yeah well well first and
foremost Kayla and I are moving together
that's so exciting we have a new dog
ramen I know
stories are oh okay we FaceTime non-stop
in the last two days because I had
business and media stuff here so I
couldn't be there but ramen seems like
the most loving dog in the world if you
haven't see him checking about ramen and
the golden noodles grab followers but
then Kaitlyn and I have some really cool
things going on together and separately
so we have heard wine business is
launching presale was incredible they
sold out in four hours her scrunchie
line does very well and I'm helping her
kind of help drive growth with that via
capital fundraising things like that and
then also I have a lot of my own stuff
like entrepreneurial stuff coming up so
I'm just looking forward to kind of us
being like a team a family from a
personal perspective and a business
perspective and like I just get so
excited thinking yeah like I can't wait
to go home tomorrow and meet Robert I'm
like so there was his flight was delayed
so I was supposed to meet him then come
to New York and then I couldn't and I
had the New York thing planned for like
months so I couldn't get out a bunch of
I couldn't get out
I'm the best feeling having a son
there's really nothing is ramen a boy or
girl he's a boy
yeah we got to set him up with you know
I guess I'll follow
Jason Tariq on instagram at Jason
underscore underscore Tariq you keeping
up with all of his ventures thank you so
much for being here thank you guys for
tuning in we're back tomorrow with our
final episode of the week thank you for
tuning in to the morning toast the
millennium morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time our YouTube and we're also Bella's
podcast anywhere you can find podcasts
so subscribe and thumbs up and all that
[ __ ] bye
you